this hey babe we got deep we talked
about mk ultra government conspiracies
ancient civilizations the mandela effect
mandela effect we kind of went wild but
it was all
noah's ark and it was all allegedly
allegedly we got crazy we got wild this
is a different speed um and uh i think
this episode i like i like going i like
going to these levels with these
episodes i like getting deep getting
kind of deep into the internet
you gave me a history like a history
lesson
you're well read i'm a well-read kid
yeah but and then also what also is uh
what you can catch up on some reading is
on netflix if you watch especially
watching my comedy special there it is
savilecanoncomedy.com for all my dates
right now uh including vegas seattle
portland vancouver boulder colorado and
phoenix
uh and uh christy comedy.com i will be
in providence rhode island in the first
week of july and at the end of august i
will be in los angeles at the improv
christy comedy.com and sal is my father
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate
[Music]
hey babe what's going on baby speaking
of working out yeah i like your shirt
okay okay because what your shirt
reminds me of
tablecloth
a tablecloth
but also it reminds me of like a native
american
you got sacagawea vibes i got some santa
julia yeah and is that what this this
isn't a native it's a native american
it's a it's it it's very native i would
say the people listening to this on at
the various reservations across the
midwest and arizona enjoy this shirt
okay
this is a
elton john yellow brick road concert tee
underneath it did pimp were you the one
telling me they found the yellow brick
road underneath the water let me pull it
up they think it's the road to atlantis
and in the bottom of the pacific ocean
how wild is that at the bottom isn't
that real
if pimp says it's real i i i believe it
i've declared it's real pimp's declared
it's real you know isn't it a greek
mythology atlantis no no well here's the
thing i've listened a lot of graham
hancock do you know graham hancock i've
probably spoken about him i've been i've
been consuming his youtube videos i've
now crossed today people really don't
call him graham [ __ ]
yeah
no i don't know him i don't know who
that is so he's like believes in
alternative history he's a big guy like
noah's ark and all that because he's
saying that we say that history started
human started in the i think it's the
sumerian culture like 5000 bc but he's
saying there's evidence from 10 000 bc
of more culture starting and more things
happening and basically at the end of
the ice age
when the ice cap started to melt you
would have seen
great floods and great cities being
consumed underwater therefore atlantis
could be a real place because like these
great magnificent cities could
absolutely be underwater if you just
forget about the fact that society uh uh
civilization started five thousand years
ago instead started ten thousand fifteen
thousand years ago so what this is the
yellow brick road historian who is he
he's a he's a he's an alternative
historian so but that's what it is like
but he you know as a phd publishes all
these things but because he's the
archaeologist hate him because he's
basically saying i disagree with
your findings because
so basically like literally five years
ago if you would have said
society started in 5000 bc with the
sumerian people
everyone would have taken that as fact
but then they just found goldbecky tepi
it's called have you heard of this no so
goblecky gobeki tepi is a
civilization that was found in turkey
that was just on earth i think in like
2017 2018 and it's from like 9 thousand
years ago so with 100
techie
yeah google goldbecky do you know what
i'm talking about pimpy yeah yeah google
go go black i think it's called blacky
tappy go becky
t-a-t-e-p-p-i
it's it's an ancient turk it's in turkey
once you go blecky though
you can't
once you go black you never go back yeah
you said go lucky i said right yeah is
that uh it screws up the whole timeline
of history so it's all
up in the air so that's what but there's
but when it screws up the timeline of
history like gobekli tepe did is
people the the science community pushes
back because then it undoes all the work
because they were saying 5000 bc was
when society started now this is saying
12 000 years ago this thing was built
and there's evidence of farming and
animal domestication so it wipes away
the idea of society started in the
mesopotamia
sure but but but
aren't scientists
and archaeologists
assisting him in this theory because
they're the one testing it so how do
they not like him isn't this like a
major discovery for all of them yeah
well the guy who discovered this his
name was klaus schmidt he died
he
thinks
that
what they did was what these people did
was
was
built a city and then intentionally
covered it with a mound like they
intentionally covered their own city for
some reason and then it was found so can
you pull it back up so people would go
like if you literally
ten years ago children were just playing
on this mound of dirt look at that
that's actually that's open concept it's
nice yeah so like and exactly there's
like what three and a half baths airbnb
it's big money on that they were playing
on this
wait is this the same is this the same
thing over and over as you just show me
examples of it are all these pictures
the same thing yeah so why isn't it and
they think why is it under a dome there
well because now archaeologists are
digging and they only think that they've
unearthed about five percent of it they
think that it is a massive structure
that could have had a full society
literally think about how long ago five
thousand years was from today think
about how long ago that was about five
thousand it was five thousand years ago
right a long time
three thousand
so think about the difference between us
and people from five thousand years ago
now think about
five thousand years before that they
were saying there was a society so
that's what they're saying is like how
advanced were they right some
researchers even claiming it was the
site of the biblical garden of eden some
people think this is where they think
the old testament was written out of
this gobeki tepe wow
but that's the thing with archaeology
and discovery is it is it is it it's
constantly evolving but you have people
very set in their ways that are like we
don't want to believe it because the
history books a different but it's like
well this this
this this is science disproving science
isn't it that's what it is so you who
who said you said before noah's ark
who's believing that so not know is so
they believe that
there was probably because of the ice
age and the polar caps melting people
going around building arks to get from
what is now land it was covered
underwater with animals and farmers and
there may have been a guy
that looked like that was an inspiration
that was inspo for noah's ark and then
that
inspo that was inspo for noah's ark and
that story was written so it's not
out of place
i see so it's not like that two of them
is however we got every animal again
it's just like they were trying to
salvage yeah the two of every kind might
be just some [ __ ] that a writer made
but they're saying that parts of the old
testament were probably they thinking if
if society is
because it's pretty much like
literally like the thing is with the
sumerian culture is like this we are go
from hunter-gatherers just in little
tribes little clans to immediately
domesticating animals and farming like
overnight like in 20 years so they're
like how did that happen right how the
[ __ ] did that happen it's like
impossible how are we for all this time
doing it this way and then out of
nowhere like that and nobody could
understand why well now with this
finding of gobek gobekli tepe people
like graham hancock and other
archaeologists that are like-minded like
him are like
those hunter-gatherers from the sumerian
culture may have found
tepe or may have found books that they
were doing it for years but then where
the where did they go right where did
gobekli tepee go why did they cover
their [ __ ] up right nobody knows
anything
so that's why it gets wild when you
think about it and then you talk about
the anunnaki people who believe who they
think they're the ones who built the
pyramids and they think they were alien
people and you see drawings of them and
from all from the caves of australia to
the caves of freaking north carolina
it's wild babe youtube is wild you go
down these halls honestly other than
watching especially washi on netflix i
pretty much only watch youtube yeah i i
here's what i gather there's a lot we
don't know probably
a hundo now have you ever thought about
what they're gonna dust off of our time
in the future
oh my god
you imagine they just dust off like a
picture of gary busey
[Laughter]
he was a leader
i have such a fun picture of me and gary
busey
we have to it's my goal in life to have
gary on the pod i know i know that you
know him i know and you said
i want to have busy on the pot
that's my wish it's easy
if it's going to be a wild night it's
going to be a while after that last
episode my goal is to have uh priestess
or shaman come here and you guys do
ayahuasca
is it leagues why not yeah sure i think
it is actually everything did will smith
do it
and look look yeah yeah i thought i just
read that like this last week like will
smith
wait uh did i ever tell you about the
time that i found out um
when i found out that noah's ark wasn't
real like i was a kid because i went to
catholic schools they teach you all this
stuff but it wasn't like exactly i was
said fifth grade right
teachers tell us about uh the bible and
about uh
this and that and then i raised my hand
she's talking about uh adam and eve okay
so i raised my hand fifth grade i said
uh miss d i said uh is isn't uh is is it
or adam and eve white
and she goes yeah
and i said uh-huh
and i raised my hand again and she's
like yeah and i go uh were they the
first two people she goes yeah i go oh
okay and i raised my head again and i
think she's so was going and i go
missy if adam and eva white and they're
the first two people how do we have any
other race
how do we have black people
and i had black friends in the class and
uh
wait were you doing this to be like to
be like a dick no i was just genuine
yeah because up until that point they're
just telling you to say you're like yeah
all right all right and i'm like wait
but what i cracked a little hole in it
yeah and then uh as soon as i said how
do we have an immigration like black
people everyone in the class like looked
up and looked at her and they were just
like hanging on her words and she was
like well you know guy
like you know maybe like everything in
the bible
like
didn't really happen
she goes the way we and the class who
went [ __ ] nuts everyone's like what
what are you talking about like i'm into
that they're just like this is what
happened this is what happened is
whatever we think we're learning history
through the bible and she's like well we
just like they said they're like stories
to help you understand values and we
were like it's
yeah everyone's raised their hand and
[ __ ] and they're just asking different
things she's like no no no and it was
like it was like deaf comedy people like
what about knowing the r because she
goes i don't know
like get the [ __ ] out yeah like some
five some fifth grade because i was like
mrs what's her name
uh her name was miss demaris okay mr so
say miss d tell me did noah build that
[ __ ] army
like tell me it's a yes or no question
[ __ ]
screaming at you
we were just screaming out passages and
she was like
every everyone went home that day told
their parents there was a thing yeah
yeah no well i mean well that's the
thing is is is i think now in catholic
schools my daughter goes to catholic
school they're kind of teaching it from
the beginning where it's like this don't
take this as fact we're not saying the
bible is fact sex facts
stories
yeah this thing i had nothing my
daughter knows that that it's like
they're kind of like stories to help
guide you through life because you can't
say it's facts like facts anymore with
the internet because i'll go on youtube
right now my daughter will go on youtube
right now yeah and tell you what's facts
and what's not right right
so this is interesting this ancient
forest was found in a 630 foot deep
sinkhole so the reason why this is
interesting is because
you know we have all this stuff here we
have a full planet if an asteroid hit
this planet today wiped everything out
we would get covered in so much
dirt soot and rubble over the course of
a hundred thousand years it would be
like we never existed so that's why
they're saying well sinkholes are even
scarier than that because they just
happened they could happen in manhattan
any any day yeah sinkholes sinkholes are
you know yeah it's it's like you know
you literally just the earth just
swallows but saying like life on mars or
you know societies that are 5 000 years
in the past how can just all how can
they be like how could there be no trace
but it's like it's actually a lot
simpler than you think right
imagine think about how long five
thousand again let's go back to five
thousand years ago and then think about
people from five thousand years ago they
didn't have half the [ __ ] we have they
didn't have they don't know anything
here we have do
they were building huts and all that if
they just went away and left those huts
gone and you know some thing happened a
meteor hit or whatever the people in
another 5 000 years there would be zero
trace of them because the earth just
take the earth will take it back in 100
years right imagine 5 000 years right
right so that's what it is that's what
archaeologists are trying to say is like
you're not giving the earth enough
credit that it can cover up
our it can cover our [ __ ] up like that
yeah mama
yeah mom earth can mama earth can turn
the room over immediately like
she'll turn it over it looks like rails
got to turn over the room
that's exactly right
uh how was rayos
rayoz was fantastic i'm wearing the same
outfit i just i actually i i um
i went in this outfit rails was good i
had the lasagna okay and katya or pepe
okay literally they came out they
started singing um
uh they actually sang my way by frank
sinatra okay rolled in frank sinatra's
coffin
special night it's special night tanks
in our trail frank sinatra tank and
frank sinatra okay they and then they
say the um because you know you say oh
we see people who are there who do you
think was there with me i'll give you
one guess who was sitting with me at
rios tom brady
and patrick mahomes where they are
together with me at the table next door
and i walked over them i said
tom
it's unbelievable that you won the super
bowl last year technically now two years
ago in tampa bay yeah in the city
that was hosting super bowl it's never
been done as the oldest player and then
i turned to my homes i said i'd be
remiss if i didn't say this to you yeah
congratulations to you as well yeah
you're an up-and-coming guy yeah and
you're great yeah
and then the odds that they were at
rails like was unbelievable yeah
unbelievable the pope was there um
speaking of tom brady get ready for a
slurry of avocado ice cream and deflated
football jokes tom brady has signed up
to be roasted as part of a new deal with
netflix
avocado ice cream what does that have to
do with it because he only he eats
avocado ice cream and and he alleges you
know and i've told you he's never eaten
a strawberry
allegedly
now do you want should we try to
campaign to get on this roast
oh wow funny the roast top she should be
on we'd do like a dog why are we not on
the roast yeah who's who's roasting them
what would you guys say
he he signed a roast deal with netflix
did you see that he signed a
more lucrative uh broadcasting deal than
his actual athlete like football deal
really i think he signed with fox sports
a 10 million 307 a 10-year 375 million
dollar contract with them to begin after
next year but my thing is this and i i
heard you only made 300 million as a
player that begins once he retires
anytime
here's the bottom line okay if you have
any type of business uh any type of
e-commerce business or any type of
business at all and you don't have ship
station you are messing up oh my god it
do you want it you have to ask yourself
a question you got a business do you
want to make your life easy or hard you
want fedex ups usps you want all them
running right through your kitchen
this is how you do it you get great uh
as good as as the bigger places and you
ship everything you get all the rates
ahead of time you could right am i crazy
no you're not crazy this is never this
is never only expressed they don't ship
station's wild okay
ships because e-commerce sellers like
you guys time to do what you really love
uh unless what you really love is
managing sales every single day out of
every single little detail you gotta you
guys have to get ship station that
automates all time intensive uh shipping
processes so you can get back to
focusing on the bigger things like your
business like developing new products
honing your strategies interacting with
customers shipstation is already trusted
by 100 sellers 98 of companies that use
shipstation for a year keep using it for
as long as they're in business so i'm
telling you that's a wild statistic
that's great ship station if it's time
to let go of all those shipping tasks
because ship station can do it better
and faster who wants to sit around doing
inventory and taking all all those
ledgers and that minutiae no oh my god
shipstation will do it and right now if
you sign up using the promo code hey
babe you get a free 60-day trial today
at shipstation.com
and you start saving time with every
shipment can i tell you uh yeah
you could also just compare like i said
before you can compare carriers rates
delivery times and you choose the best
option for your scenario right in front
of you the the the power to have that
is ridiculous that's the real 98
of of companies that use it uh for a
year use it as long as they've been in
business just go to shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in hey babe ship
station make ship happen and let's go
ship yourself that's right and that's
two whole months of shipping made quick
and painless and it's free to try this
ship crazy
blenders eyewear
fresh from san diego california comes
the only sunglasses brand that you're
ever going to wear again that i'm never
going to wear again i'm talking about
blenders eyewear people and you're going
to be just as hooked when you see how
awesome the shades are they're perfect
to wear them uh
you you got yours i got my blenders
eyewear i love it you have them in my
car right now yeah yeah i wear them
because they weren't first of all they
weren't expensive they're onyx you know
these big brand shades they're costing
hundreds hundreds of dollars not
blenders they're actually affordable um
they were started by this guy chase
fisher who he was a hip cat yeah he was
selling beachy shades out of a backpack
while he was a surf instructor on the
pacific beach and then he created this
this eyewear that's like literally what
he said he wanted to do he wanted to
create an adventurous mid-priced eyewear
option with the same cool factor as the
leading brands and blenders has
prescription glasses readers and blue
lights as well as a snow collection with
goggles and accessories my stepson has
the uh prescription glasses and he loves
him gets compliments on them all the
time the thing about it too is because
it is so cheap when you inevitably lose
and or crush your glasses like i have
done to the last 15 pairs you don't have
a full heart attack right
so
right now
to score 15 off your blender's purchase
visit
blenderseyeware.com and enter promo code
hey babe vip that's blenders
blenderseyewear.com
code heybay vip for 15 off blenders
rocked with pride worldwide
wow look at this we can't wait to burn
three-time super bowl losing quarterback
tom brady we only went back to the nfl
in order to delay this roast netflix
vice president of stand-up comedy
formats robbie prawl who is the man who
gave me my netflix special uh
that's insane about these people it's
like yeah he called me was like yeah if
whatever give me a [ __ ] special and
then immediately probably called tom
brady and was like tom yeah
and you already make your own bread you
already make exactly i make my own bread
yeah i don't need anybody else's crumbs
that's correct you know what i'm talking
about um
but i i i the thing is with me is money
ain't everything it ain't everything
right but money anything jermaine dupree
i think said that money ain't a thing
money anything yeah
i think that
i don't know
but tom brady has made so much money
i just don't know that i'd go back into
a broadcasting booth
i don't know that he loves football
though right i guess he lives he lives
and breathing and if he's not gonna play
it at that level i don't i don't know
dude honestly if i made his money i
might just walk around punching people
in the face right in the face and i'm
not even violent you get in jail right
away yeah
over covet overcrowding
scientists reverse death bring dead eyes
back to life
i don't know about this
what do you mean they brought the dead
a's dead eyes back to life i'm confused
i think somebody was brain dead and they
got the eyes to respond to light again
the discovery that oh wow this is crazy
so you said okay eyes taken from organ
donors five hours after death responded
to light raises
responded to light raises the question
of whether brain death as it is
currently defined is truly irreversible
interesting so you're saying after the
brain has been declared legally dead the
eye still responded to light yeah like
zombie kind of stuff yeah
that's very very very very very very
very wild if you guys could opt out of
death would you
opt out yeah like it was a mailer
only if my family could opt out as well
i wouldn't want to live without loved
ones and people i know
that's fair yeah i don't want to outlive
everybody with something that i don't
want to do
that i don't want to do
but if you knew you weren't going to die
would you even care about your
cholesterol
no i wouldn't care about my cholesterol
you're not going to die
it don't matter your cholesterol is high
it's hard to get high cholesterol what
are you eating
hi the red meat red meat but i have high
cholesterol but i've had i've had high
cholesterol since i'm 10.
i had high cholesterol as a 10 year old
oh really yeah oh that could be maybe
dangerous yeah and but my blood my blood
pressure's high too but it's always been
mine too but it's
yeah but the meds make it low or it's
still higher than a average i still feel
like it's still kind of high like not
like it could be a little higher than
normal but it's not always it's not
always five over eighty it's not always
yeah it's never it's not always like
right on the button or anything i don't
know i'm talking to my doctor now about
possibly switching the medication what
are you going to switch it to
this is so funny it sounds like we're at
an old age home yeah
i don't know i don't know nothing about
meds but i do want to tell you that i
want to talk about the mandela effect
talk to me about the nelson mandela yeah
from from before so remember we talked
about how that thing about how you're
how you can believe something because
you could remember the last
version of what you stored in your brain
so you start remembering memories and
they they do they so i saw i leave here
today
i'm thinking back to this time two weeks
ago two weeks from now i'm thinking back
i'm remembering your shirt was black but
in fact it's navy blue but in my head
i'm remembering it's black as that
memory goes on you had on a black shirt
in my head not a navy blue shirt yeah or
like in 40 years from now you might be
like oh we were here that day and who
else was there and it was someone i
don't know i don't know but but you've
heard of the berenstain bears thing
you've heard that right no do you know
the barons
do you have baron do you know the
berenstain bears they were a big cartoon
and oh yeah book series book series
yeah they're the best cartoons and
everything okay
okay i used to get those books all the
time from scholastic and stuff like the
berenstain bears was my [ __ ] okay okay
there's this phenomenon where people
remember it
large groups of people so that's the
mandela things when large groups of
people agree
that they also remember something a
certain way and it was never that way
so berenstain bears
oh there's 45 examples
they people thought it was spelled one
way
and they swore by it on the books and it
was spelled a different way see so
people
thought it was spelled like but
everybody like like thousands and
thousands and thousands of people swear
they spelled it one way and it was just
never
never correct and and all these people
like i know for a fact all these people
like it's actually a thing
sex in the city sex in the city and sex
in the city is a big one i always
thought it was sex and the city
these i i no these are that's not real
mandela effects one the berenstain one
is
wait a minute go back to the go back to
that king henry the eighth one what's
the problem with this one
turkey leg
oh yeah well that's this is just
different interpretations
monopoly guy
oh did he not have a monocle
nice that's awesome you know what that's
called a monocle
you knew it
i know but i feel like i would have to
think about what is that called again
but you monocle was on the tip of your
tongue like it's almost like you used
you've used the word monocle this week
i haven't but i just know what a monocle
is like every time 10 out of 10 you
monocle immediately i don't i don't
forget that monocle yeah yeah
well anyway that that's the mandela
effect i thought it was more going to be
more interesting for you it is it is
interesting though could you could you
oh okay there's no that's another big
one that's another big one that i think
shackles so one of the most well-known
ones
a collective memory of a movie called
shazam which was starred actor comedian
sinbad in the 90s
i thought that
he it
i really thought that that sinbed was in
shazam and he wasn't it was shaq's movie
right no that's kazam
i think
oh so who was in shazam
click on that click on that i don't know
the mandela effect
no but it'll save in the article
no now that's the new shazam that's the
new shazam we go back to that go back to
that actual
link shazam sinbad what is mandela
effect
in fact no such movie exists at all
there was a children's movie called
kazam and some other coincidence that
could help to explain how this movie
became created or remembered in many
people's minds wow so there was never a
shazam with sinbad it was kazam with
shaq yeah but why do we all remember
shazam with sinbad i don't i don't know
well there is and i know i don't know if
we've talked about it on chrissy chaos
or if we talked about it here on hey
babe
the the mk ultra stuff
is also huge where the cia was
manipulating many people's minds with mk
ultra like what is mk ultra mk ultra is
um
mind control that the cia proved that
they could do and a lot of people think
mkultra is being used on people at
different points in their life for
different reasons it's not like the end
of zoolander that kind of thing yes it's
like brainwashing techniques through lsd
the drug lsd was created through
mkhitaryan
was the code name of an illegal human
experimentation program designed and
undertaken by the us the cia is are you
serious yeah and this stuff is real mk
ultra is a real thing and they and they
developed procedures and identified
drugs such as lsd that could be used in
interrogations to weaken individuals and
force confessions through brainwashing
and psychological torture they a lot of
people think the conspiracies that
charles manson was under the influence
of mkultra and that's why what happened
happened and
he's like the cia scapegoat because it
was an mk ultra experiment gone wrong i
don't know if that's true but that's a
conspiracy i never heard of that yeah
don't you kind of think social media has
a vibe this kind of does have a vibe of
that where it's like where it's like
you
you know you're under the influence of
like this you know like even social
media even getting trapped i mean do you
realize how
and it's happened to me many times i'm
sure it's time for the people at home
how someone's comments on this
fake app
that i don't know at all have hurt me
and like ruin my day in real time where
i'm like i don't even physically know
who you are but somehow you got inside
my mind it is like a mind control
thing where you're like i don't even you
could live in a different part of the
world i don't know who you are at all
right and you got inside my head yes wow
it doesn't seem
good and this mk ultra stuff allegedly
like they have they cia says they
stopped it but a lot of people think
they haven't but who were they
administering it to they were trying to
do this was like cold war stuff i
believe and like
you know kind of like for america's
enemies to like be able to control their
brains but who were they testing it on
was that wasn't manson one of them
that's what they said charles manson
could have been one of them and they
think other groups of people
like they think they tested on people
unknowingly like people oh you gotta be
kidding me that's what they think
the thing is here's the thing here's the
thing what i've watched what i've
learned about
you know just doing research and
watching youtube and all that stuff and
blah blah is is
we also the united states i am a patriot
baby make no mistake i love this country
but we are have a state-run media we
think you know you say oh
north korea's got a state-run media and
so do we yeah they put forward exactly
what they want you to know in here oh
you have to deep d
da deep dive into the internet to find
out well here's actually what
there's a lot of alternative theories on
to what america just put forward to you
so this is one of those things where
like a lot of people believe and how
yeah one project mk ultra got underway
in april 1953 experiments included
administering lsd to mental patients
prisoners drug addicts and prostitutes
people who could not fight back
so they just gave them lsd
and saw what happened to him and a lot
of that stuff out of the noremberg code
which is you know the code that was made
after you know all the nazi crimes they
think that a lot of this stuff was
happening in the holocaust that is why i
read a book called the nazi symbiosis
that pretty much said the reason why the
united states and the western powers did
not intervene immediately when they
found out about the holocaust is because
the nazis were getting like trying out
all types of crazy [ __ ] on you know the
jewish people in the holocaust that they
were yielding kind of like some results
on certain things that the western
powers like wait what can we learn from
this let's let them do it and then they
only intervened when
the they stopped yielding results and
hitler just started like killing
everyone and and uh who's that's when
they intervened yeah i mean that's what
this
history says lsd and other drugs were
often administered without the subject's
knowledge or informed consent a
violation of the nuremberg code the us
had agreed to follow after world war ii
the aim of this was to find drugs which
would bring out deep confessions or wipe
a subject's mind clean
and program them as a robot agent holy
god damn [ __ ] yep yep in midnight
in operation midnight climax
the cia set up several brothels
within agency safe houses in san
francisco to obtain a selection of men
who would be too embarrassed to talk
about the events
the men were dosed with lsd the brothels
were equipped with one-way mirrors and
the sessions were filmed for later
viewing and study in other experiments
where people were given lsd without
their knowledge they were interrogated
under bright lights with doctors in the
background taking notes they told
subjects they would extend their trips
if they refused to reveal their secrets
the people under this interrogation were
cia employees u.s military personnel and
asian suspected of working for the other
side in the cold war long-term
debilitation and several deaths resulted
from this heroin addicts were bribed
into taking lsd with offerings that is
interesting but it never went away
epstein continued this yeah this is
still going on right now that's what i'm
that's what they think is like a lot of
this epstein's island stuff and a lot of
stuff like
it's kind of like control efforts by the
government to control people at the
highest levels their say basically
hey
you can
tell all these secrets that you know or
use your money to do this or do that but
if you do we have videos of you having
sex with an underage child type stuff
and then when people go against the
grain or whatever the videos are
released the hammer comes down on you
for whatever things you may have done
that's conspiracies out there is that
when you get to a certain level
people start to become like you know
because sometimes you wonder why does
this person or this athlete take this
stance or why do they do that when they
know it's wrong and it's it might be
because well the powers that be whoever
that are have a lot of
kind of dirty laundry on you you think
there's an illuminati
i don't know if there's an illuminati
i i do though think
that there is certainly i would almost
say 100
a group of people
way higher than presidents people that
we've never heard of that are not on any
list that don't want to be on lists of
the richest people in the world that
will never be that probably can't be
that do pull strings of that i'm not
even i'm not saying our the politicians
even know who they are right but i think
that it's happening you just think
there's people more powerful than we
know the fact that jazlyn maxwell is
doing great like nothing's happening to
her is crazy yeah she's just fine with
hard proof
yeah well she's still in prison though
yeah yeah she's never gonna get
sentenced she's never gonna yeah she'll
get she'll get i mean she's never gonna
get sentenced it keeps getting
everything keeps getting pushed i i mean
and the amount of human traffickers that
keep getting caught and no one reports
it is terrifying like there's crates of
children in the middle of the country
right
like there's footage of it and the news
just doesn't
it's a really weird thing man
right
no it's took a turn
well i was just saying like the like
like there's also this thing called the
havana syndrome which is like uh um
different members of you know the
government and military they'll just get
like like all of a sudden out that
worked in around the havana cuba area
started getting like these intense like
buzzing in their brains would almost
have like stroke-like symptoms and it
happened to all these people and the
same things were happening to them and
they all worked in the same companies
and had a note and they think that their
brains were being controlled or
something wasn't planted in them that
could they had all these people had
knowledge of a high level thing
wild and they all got the same thing
they all got the same stuff some of them
some of them happened in u.s soil too
some of them never recovered no movie
about this sure there's one being like
this is an ongoing like 2017 like this
is ongoing this is judd apatow's new
movie is it gonna be about
yeah
um you ever see you ever go to the
bodies exhibit yeah
fascinating right that was down by the
south shore seaport you know who they
were
well that's what i was gonna bring there
was a controversy with that too right
because speaking yeah they were homeless
people that passed away right no they
believed that they were they were um
they were chinese slaves
they believed that they were they were
they were oh i had read that they were
unidentified asia like homeless bodies a
lot of them were asian and that that it
was a controversy because they didn't
have
the right to
right to do that but you're saying
they were saying that like it was in
parts of china like it was chinese
slave bodies that's what they're saying
but from when i don't know like i guess
that time
yeah where did the bodies from the
exhibit come from are all chinese men
and women provided by the dallian
medical university plantation in china
uh yeah so they they don't think that it
was like
on the opposite side
so that's but that's just a
straightforward answer there's no
controversy there well yeah but it's
it's you know well the controversy is
nobody's checking in on that company
right
i mean this has been going on since the
beginning of this country remember
benjamin franklin told us they would
grave rob and philly like constantly
yeah benjamin franklin we went out with
benjamin franklin impersonator we took
ayahuasca
i honestly remember i was like
how much weed did you smoke today
so in i been smoked in a month oh really
yeah right on wow there you go did you
go through it a little bit oh yeah dude
i couldn't sleep for weeks you couldn't
sleep for weeks when you when you
stopped smoking when it was a day i just
started vomiting
and you think for sure that was
withdrawals oh yeah i think insomnia i i
would say yes sweating and stuff at
night no edibles either but my dreams
are terrible
at one time with you headaches
for the first two weeks it was like i'm
like what is wrong with me yeah
what's the reasoning you think you
stopped doing it just i always like
after like a couple years take like six
months off just to so you'll do it again
eventually oh yeah why not i'm gonna be
bored of everything again yeah right
right but just for now why not why not
yeah um so um
um thank you so rob graves the uh not
benjamin franklin the colonial people
used to rob graves and then they would
just use their body for science so the
thing is it's inhumane and it sucks but
you don't have certain types of
advancements in science or all this
stuff without kind of because back then
people weren't donating their bodies to
science back then yeah or they were just
like you know he was saying the
commoners were robbing the graves and
selling it to the medical schools
selling to them that led to new graves
being built
like grave defenses
right oh like better like more secure
graves yeah oh wow
yeah i mean you know
it's um i could i could use the coffee
myself babe i rock my peloton
if you're a person that doesn't have a
peloton now like what are you even doing
like what are you doing i love peloton
because it is fun it's communal it's
motivating it i love that you can just
the music selections and and the
instructors you can peg who you like and
put them in your favorites and you take
their classes along with other people
you just feel like you're part of a
community it just is invigorating it
doesn't feel like you're just in a room
alone just spinning your wheels cycling
strength training yoga running it's not
just a bike and you're more likely to
stick to a workout routine you enjoy so
peloton makes every class fun so it
feels like you're hanging out with your
friends if you're in the mood for a ride
full of club bangers an edm run yoga
flow class with soul music whatever you
want to do peloton's got it for you um
oh and you know what i like about it
the quick ones 10 minutes that's 10
minutes that's where that's my
wheelhouse
you know you do it in between calls
whatever it's you could do a 40-minute
run you could do a 10-minute session it
is really fits your your needs uh it
works with your schedule whether you
have five minutes or an hour plus you'll
never have an awkward encounter in that
locker room again never ever ever you
could get on your peloton butt ass naked
it don't matter right now is the perfect
time to try our peloton the peloton bike
plus is now five hundred dollars
it's the best price yet including free
delivery and setup and there are more
game changing prices available on the
original peloton bike and peloton tread
visit one peloton.com to learn more
upstart baby if you got high interest
debt and all that stuff you got high
interest credit cards sometimes it's
hard to see the end in sight that's zero
balance it's just hard and upstart is
the place that can help you out they
have upstart has powered personal loans
that can help you pay down high interest
debt all online high interest credit
card debt high interest credit card debt
with simple and easy to understand
payment terms upstart has helped over
1.8 million customers on their path to
financial freedom you want to pay off
credit cards you want to consult that
financial independence don't ask it's
hard to ask other people too take it
take control to your own hands yeah and
you could check your rate in minutes for
loans between 1 000 and 50 000 without
impacting your credit score well they
know that you're more than just a credit
score so rather than looking at your
credit score alone upstart model
considers other factors like your income
your employment and other information
provided in your loan application don't
wait and check your rate today at
upstart.com hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe to check your rate today do not
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you loan amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application go to
upstart.com
you can receive funds as fast as one
business they enter accepting a loan
whoa upstart.com
oh wow
yeah i mean you know
it's um i could i could have used the
coffee myself you could use the coffee
yeah something something i don't even
know if it does anything to me
coffee my father drinks coffee at night
isn't that weird yeah coffee before bed
yeah i i don't know if it does anything
for me actually to tell you the truth
but i'm saying all i need is i could use
a pep a week you take a five hour end
i haven't taken a five hour energy until
i drank a red bull in
15 years yeah you take those no but what
does this mean a red bull ice nah i i i
mean i don't even know like what's the
last time you had a red bull
incidentally maybe i had to be with a
vodka at a party and i didn't know is
red bulls are there numbers going down
because i don't know anyone who's drank
a red bull in a long time yeah i don't
know
they sponsored that space jumper
how great was that um no i um i uh i
took it i i used to have it on my rider
okay because i just i'm so i'm just so
have a five hour energy to have a red a
five hour energy okay like in case i
just like got what does that feel like
i've never done one of those yeah it's
just like it's as i assume it's like
coffee you know it just like
can potentially just kind of get you
going a little bit
i don't know i i only would do it in
desperate situations but i did do
remember when my cousins drank three red
bulls and had to be rushed to the
hospital they had to be rushed to the
hospital yeah it made like a heart
like oh
three yeah people in the clubs
nightclubs when that was i don't know if
it's still a thing but people just have
10 plus of those things all night long
redwill some people are more sensitive
jasmine used to work at sound factory in
iconic no way i love in new york city
yeah she was a bartender at sound no way
you know she told me when she was like
21 22 she used to work at sound factory
and in one i went what do you think she
made in one night as a as a bartender
not even a bartender
at the on the main room the bartender
downstairs that was pretty much only
giving out she said
water sodas and red bulls because
everybody was because everybody was so
[ __ ] up what do you think she made in
tonight and she was like i'm positive i
made that number well just take a guess
in cash as a 22 year old girl in one
night doing running the water red bull
and soda bar well i'll tell you right
now because if people are on ecstasy
and they're not spending all that
although they probably charge 10 bucks
for a water but people are probably in a
great mood generous
they go to her she goes to watch
everyone's i don't know if you've ever
been to she's hot hot spanish girl a
nightclub like that though have you ever
did you ever go to a nightclub when it
was that was all the rage and everything
tunnel and all that yes
all that limelight all that i went to
all of them wow and it was crazy because
everybody in there was on if you didn't
do it and you walked in you'd be like yo
what is going on like everybody it's not
like they were like tripping out or
anything but it's just everyone's
drinking water and it's like
best friends right it's wild like there
was a wild
a year maybe a year where i used to go
all the time
and
you got to a point where you can go to a
nightclub in the city alone and show up
and know that you would know like
literally going into a comedy club
you see the same people that you spent
nights with already you showed what
clubs would you go to in the city all
the iconic ones limelight tunnel you
have memories palladium limelight
tunnel
uh uh
sound factory none of them are there
anymore those are my big ones no is
there even an iconic nightclub now pimp
that people go to i asked this recently
and i found out there there is still
those types of clubs in the city we just
i have no idea like i don't hear them in
the conversation or anything i think i'd
love to see you guys there now
we should just do a live stream i heard
a marquee
15 years old already isn't it like it's
not like a thing like would you ever go
to a nightclub now on like so
unappealing the only time it ever
happens is if i'm on a road and a night
like a nightclub in that area reaches
out and says come by for just we'll give
you a section we'll give you a bot like
like that and that's been even years
maybe vegas
i don't even know i don't know we went
nac that was fun
that was okay that was probably the
first time i did that in
i'm gonna say eight years or something i
don't know i love that the first time
you went was at the height of covett
no but we we it was just like we were
we're at porgata and we had this whole
section afterwards and then they came in
they're like oh we're fans we got this
nightclub over here just come over and
we'll give you some bottles and so when
we thinned out we were down to like 10
people we're like
should we walk over there and we did and
it was like old it was like old school
it was like we were sitting there and
just drinking laughing and stuff so what
what do you think she i think she made
so in one night i know that she made i
know it's thousands because even me my
best night bartending ever and that was
at a local watering hole as looking like
i do
was 1201 so my guess if she did a full
shift i bet you she she came away with
what two grand five thousand dollars i
was just saying one night in cash she
was her rent at that time she had a
roommate her rent was 150
for her rent and she said she only spent
because she wasn't really eating that
much she was doing drugs at most a month
another 300 she said her cost of living
was no more than 500
for one month she made five thousand
dollars in one night that's because of
my first gut instinct was five and i
said that's insane then i brought it
down to 25 and i still felt guilty then
i knocked it down to two she said the
upstairs bartending girls would easily
easily make 7 500 in the night friday
night seventy five hundred dude saturday
night seven day five hundred in cash it
was packed yeah and you there used to be
a thing with people leaving that work
there they they wouldn't lead till the
afternoon because it could be dangerous
for them to leave why because the cash
they have on them people knew that i've
heard of people trying getting robbed
when you're leaving you know that when
you're a bartender and you're leaving at
night i ever tell you the fat story fat
joe told me about the club did i ever
tell you that did i ever talk about that
on the podcast it doesn't ring a bee
called fat joe and easter eggs with the
tunnel when jasmine called fat joe and
easter egg was a 10 out of 10. what jazz
the very i mean i the second date i ever
took jasmine on i i was doing a hosting
a baseball show called off the bat with
fat joe and i took her to a fat joe
concert
and we got in the green room or whatever
hanging out with fat joe and jasmine was
drunk she and in fact joe was wearing a
light blue suit a light blue velour suit
with light blue jordans and jasmine's
drunk and she goes you look like an
easter egg and he goes whose [ __ ] is
this no i swear to god i was like joe
i'm sorry it's fine he goes she's got to
get out of here no
no yeah and then we just went and then
jasmine doesn't even remember that she
doesn't remember it at all she's like i
didn't call him an easter egg i'm like
we were thrown out of the creek oh no
because you called him an easter egg but
fatchol told me story the tunnel okay
mid 90s when the tunnel was like maybe
this was 19. that's when i was there man
like so sometime between 93 and 95 yeah
it's fat joe how is it like nineteen big
pun yeah okay
height of everything
that's all big pun he's telling me the
story facho and big pun they go to the
tunnel and he said at the tunnel yeah
at that time there was a bunch of people
that would wait for
you know
rappers athletes whatever to come in and
they'll rob their chains right
he said so
fat joe and big pun
are walking in
and they
somebody puts a gun to them i'm like
give me your stuff and he said big pun
was no like notorious like not a [ __ ]
like i ain't giving you [ __ ] where fat
joe was same thing strong as [ __ ] but he
was like yo just let's give him and move
on and paul was like i'm not giving you
anything i'm not giving you anything and
they had the guns to them like for sure
would pop off
he said
out of nowhere all of a sudden
you hear some commotion outside and you
hear he said you hear a voice he goes
who [ __ ] with my man punt who [ __ ]
with puns it was mike tyson
mike tyson no he walks in he said these
gang banger
drug dealing criminals with guns to
facho and mike fatcho and big pun
immediately put their guns down
and run away from mike tyson because
they were terrified that mike tyson was
going to beat the [ __ ] out of them and
they got into the club he had no
intentions of shooting then hung out all
night but he's like that's how powerful
mike tyson was in the early 90s he
literally him he his body was a a weapon
right it was wild he's still terrifying
still could you imagine being that guy
getting punched in the face no buy mike
tyson on that plane no i i honestly
honestly i think i hate that guy just
his face the guy who got beat up by mike
i think i hate him more than bin laden
[Laughter]
i think i hate him yeah he i hate him
more he was he's he was
justin
there's no way anybody likes that guy
he sucked what a dick right what a dick
and dude
fans like that i can't believe that's
all that happened was a scrape on his
forehead i know we spoke about it on a
previous episode but i know i think we
will talk about this too but remember
that kid that got on a plane drunk and
he was like screaming like my father is
worth more than your whole life and they
duct taped him to the
duct taped into the thing and for the
rest of the flight he was duct taped
into the chair and people were just
filming him and mocking them yeah do you
remember that yeah yeah i don't know
whatever came with that kid i saw
something that i've truly never seen
in my life growing up in new york city
you know it's easy you know people make
you know
you know all these neighborhoods like uh
these deep brooklyn neighborhoods
whatever like uh you're racist this is
racist whatever yes fine it all exists i
i promise you growing up in new york
city not once in my life did i ever hear
somebody intentionally in a hurtful way
try to use a racial slur at some point i
never heard it for real like you know
i've heard people mess around do jokes
whatever but i'm talking about
intentionally like what you've seen a
movie never not once in my life until
two weeks ago i was outside a comedy
club okay
the security guard who we all know very
well black guy
white guys
drunk as [ __ ] not even at the club i
think seller or yes comedy seller
walking who's this who was it steve king
sean king yeah the big guy great guy who
there's a bouncer at the comedy comedy
cello's name is stephen king which is
why that's his actual real name so
stephen king and and
he's sitting in there
some guy
drunk white idiot stumbling by not even
online at the comedy cellar not even
online okay right just a drunk he
reminded me of that guy in the mike
types thing just a dumb hateable face
right
he's walking and then tries to get into
the club
and do some i don't you know whatever
and then you know king's like you know
get in line whatever and he was i had a
ticket whatever just and he's like all
right move on and then he tries to walk
in again so king physically has to be
like move away that's his job as a
bouncer and then the guy stumbles back
because you put your hands on me and
king's like move away move down the
block like king had enough which a man
even i had enough five minutes before
that right and king go and then guy goes
you're gonna push me and he yells the
n-word at him right which was wild
shocking where in front of a line of 100
people wow then king says i'm gonna let
that slide you're drunk as [ __ ] just get
out of here leave right now
you're drunk get out of here and
literally was like just get out of here
right
so he's stumbling around the guy he's
not moving king's just looking at him
he's like get out of here like actually
you yell that out right now on that
block you better look out yeah dude it's
it's uh it was crazy it was like so then
a few seconds go by
and and the guy goes i'm still here
n-word to him
so then king's like
it's [ __ ] crazy
so with that he goes to start to walk
towards the guy
one of the managers from the club stops
and he's like do not get involved do not
get involved like you've shown amazing
restraint up until now i don't even know
how you did that just i will take care
of it manage the white woman
the manager then starts to walk towards
that who do i know liz
starts to walk towards that guy
like poetic justice you've never seen
that guy takes one step to try to get
towards the line face plants face first
into the concrete blood
everywhere his orbital bone broke his
eye was hanging halfway out oh yeah
halfway down his face and everybody in
the line started clapping and laughing
at him and i was like
good holy honestly [ __ ] good because
it's like instant calm the thing is when
you get that drunk like people who can't
hold their liquor like that it just
bothers me what a terrible person just
bothers me because like
you know i've never done that like it's
just come on
it's all of the earth if you could get
that drunk to where like you you i mean
you're going to get oh god
i've never seen a i've never seen it in
my life but with that you can check us
out on the road
yeah yeah
with that right now uh on sale right now
i have uh milwaukee minnesota rochester
syracuse hampton
hampton beach uh and then the new ones
vegas boulder colorado uh phoenix
seattle portland and vancouver all on
sale right now savilecountedcomedy.com
and me you can go on netflix watch my
comedy special especially i am out in
providence in july and then i got uh la
brea comedy club in los angeles area uh
the brea improv in the los angeles area
at the end of august and then more dates
coming up uh in the first week of june
christy comedy.com for tiki wikis and uh
yeah man that's it oh this is coming out
this is the so this weekend i'm in
rochester and syracuse go to rochester
and syracuse and don't act like that guy
in the line or else your eye socket's
going to fall out of your face yeah
rightfully so and this has been haven
yeah i just came back from
don't rayoz a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey